the Trump administration is moving
hundreds of migrant children from a
Clint Texas Border Patrol facility where
they were held in conditions described
as squalid and unsanitary now we first
reported on those conditions there last
week Omar Villafranca is in Mission
Mission Texas where migrant families
often cross the border there Omar the
details of the story are so upsetting
and I guess the question now is where
are the kids
well good morning a spokesperson with
the office of refugee resettlement told
us that the majority of those children
in the Clint facility will now be moved
over into their care where we're not
exactly sure as for the 50 or so
children who were not being transferred
we don't know what's going to happen to
them now this all comes as attorneys
recently toured that facility in Clinton
and described children living in
unsanitary conditions we spoke to one of
the lawyers Alaura mukherjee and about
what she saw many of the children had
not had access to a single shower or
bath they were wearing the same dirty
clothing that they crossed the border
with their clothes were stained with
snot with breast milk with urine and the
children didn't have access to any soap
to wash their hands there is
insufficient food for the children
nearly every child I spoke with was
hungry many of them do not have
mattresses to sleep on they don't even
have mats they're sleeping on concrete
floors Mukherjee said some of the
children had been in the facility and
Customs and Border Patrol custody for
weeks and according to federal law
unaccompanied minors must be transferred
within 72 hours that's three days to the
office of refugee resettlement which is
a special division that knows how to
deal with children now immigrant
officials have said that their
facilities are overcrowded they're
overwhelmed with more migrants come over
the southern border we actually reached
out to CBP for comment but they did not
get back to us Tony
Omar thank you very much I think one of
the questions here is why did it take
public reporting and then public outrage
before something happens like they were
shamed into it you know these children
of course deserve better and I just
think that we are better as a country
this isn't how we treat people
these are little children it's been
very very disturbing